today I'm going to show you how to  create a table in bigquery with Ruby I'm  creating a table to track my cat  pictures the Google Cloud bigquery gem  is the easiest way to do this to use the  gem you need a project and a service  account key I created these earlier  now to create my table first I require  google cloud  now i'm going to create a big query  object groups of tables and bigquery  called data sets so i'm creating a data  set called pictures  now i can create the table i'm naming it  cats and i'm passing in the schema as a  block this is very similar to creating  migrations in rails so it should feel  natural  that's it now I have a table and  bigquery to verify that you can go to  the bigquery console reload and you'll  see there's my cat's table I hope you  found this helpful